[Música]
[Aplausos]
ashley
pesa dama diosa bueno que soy todo lo
que esperaban ver si de mentiroso
en el fondo alguien está che no sé si es
tan bella e yo para diosa del stand up
esperaba un poquito más
alguien más al fondo siendo ya está aquí
la veo la verdad
esperemos al vídeo para decir no a esa
dama diosa capaz alguien está ni
siquiera se lo que se están dando
puede ser hay alguien en la sala esté en
esas condiciones a ese río así como lo
voy a explicar de manera simple y sima
para que entendamos todos
el stand up es una manera de hacer humor
en la que está un comediante arriba de
un escenario completamente solo frente
público con la intención de hacer reír
besa dama llosa que tienen que ver estas
categorías no como en el que el estándar
a las mujeres comediantes nos presentan
de esa manera
besa dama diosa categorías que no tienen
nada que ver con la capacidad o no de
hacer reír no es cierto y categorías que
además son categorías que jamás
utilizarían para presentar a un hombre
comediante hamas en un show de stand up
a escuchar decir recibimos ahora al más
hermoso comediante de la argentina jamás
eso no pasa por qué porque vivimos en
una sociedad que todavía es machista y
el stand up es por ende todavía machista
el humor no tiene género sin embargo
aparecen categorías como el humor
femenino
el humor es humor y punto
no estamos en la en la facultad de
derecho yo creo que a nadie acá se le
ocurriría decir que una voz
cada ejerce el derecho femenino por ser
mujer no sólo cuando comencé mi carrera
un colega me invitó a participar en un
evento solidario su estado como muy
emocionada pero hacía chistes sobre sexo
entonces noche que antes le dije che vos
conocés material de parece que esto da
para que yo basa y me presenté dices y
tranquila es un evento solidario chicos
de 5º año un sábado a la noche todo
tranqui bárbaro
vamos juntos el evento 500 personas para
mí en ese momento era como un montón de
gente emocionada esperando sube al
escenario hace chistes de sexo dice
malas palabras no genera la gente súper
arriba suyo al escenario
digo la palabra que empieza con pi y
termina con top y automáticamente veo
las caras en el público transformarse de
repente fue como utilidad total
yo los veía todos vi cómo una señora se
levantaba de su asiento y se va a quejar
el mismo compañero que me había invitado
me hace a mí me bajé prácticamente
llorando le soy sincero me bajé muy mal
del escenario y cuando bajé busca una
explicación y me encontré uno de los
organizadores del evento meses y el
evento es de los chicos de 5º año pero
es para que los de 1º viajen a misionar
al norte del país
yo dije ya está hecha es obvio porque mi
material no funcionó pero viste cuando
peleas con alguien que te vas y al rato
decís hay le tendría que haber dicho
esto esto y esto me pasó exactamente lo
mismo
al rato está así como a mi casa pensando
dije momentito su viaje de dos horas de
ida dos horas de vuelta no cobró un peso
fui con mi mejor voluntad y casi vuelvo
apedreada mi colega hizo chistes más
subidos de tono que yo uso las palabras
y no pasó nada
en ese momento me cayó la ficha no era
el evento no era mi material el problema
era ser mujer
el humor no tiene género pero el entorno
de la comedia te va a hacer sentir y
creer que si el otro día sólo escribía
un productor porque me enteré que había
un nuevo lugar donde ir a hacer stand up
y escribir para pedirle una fecha para
decirle que tenía disponibilidad para
actuar visto básicamente y qué bueno
está ocupado y después hablando con otro
colega me dice no lo que pasa es que él
tiene un problema con las mujeres
él no invita a mujeres actuar porque
dice que las mujeres no son graciosas
además de tener un prejuicio él lo que
está haciendo al ser productor es
decidir por el público que es y qué no
es gracioso que vale la pena y que no
vale la pena ver voy a contarles a un
chiste preparados van una rubia y una
morocha caminando por un parque de
repente la morocha dice ay qué asco un
pájaro muerto y la rubia dice dónde
donde con un poco de delay no pero de
qué nos reímos
yo estoy convencida que el camino a una
sociedad más igualitaria
comienza por hacernos preguntas tan
simple como está de que nos reímos ese
chiste lo usa alejandro angelini que es
uno de los padres del stand up en
argentina para explicar la estructura
básica del chiste
nosotros en 'stand up tenemos una
premisa y un remate que es una premisa
una afirmación de la realidad
si algo que damos por verdadero y que el
chiste va a confirmar de qué nos reímos
de lo tonta que es la rubia buscando un
pájaro muerto en el cielo
la premisa implícita ahí es el prejuicio
las rubias son tontas no quiere decir
que todos los chistes sean prejuicios no
pero
lo usa porque les sirve para explicar lo
de manera muy fácil y yo elegí este
chiste que él usa porque también nos
sirve para ver cuántas veces nos reímos
y no nos frenamos a preguntar de qué nos
estamos riendo aún no ha habido
muchísimo dice río porque pero ésta está
bueno empezar a tomar conciencia porque
esto pasa tanto a nivel del público como
del comediante los mandatos los
prejuicios están instalados en nuestro
inconsciente que no los vemos los
comediantes los comediantes de stand up
específicamente hacemos chistes que son
nuestra visión del mundo nuestra opinión
sobre ciertos temas y a veces
afirmamos cosas que son por lo menos
polémicas por no decir horrorosas
yo estoy haciendo actualmente una
investigación para la cual tomé videos
de mujeres comediantes y se las mostré a
otras mujeres y lo que hice fue
preguntarles qué te pareció gracioso si
es que algo te pareció gracioso no de
todos los chistes que vieron uno de los
que más gracia causó fue uno que hablaba
sobre esconder el rollo y decía algo
como esto esconde es el rollo aunque a
éste hace 14 años con el mismo hombre
que nos reímos
en este caso la premisa que sigue
vigente circulando ahí es la mujer debe
ser flaca no tener rollos o si los
tienes esconderlos pero sigue siendo la
mujer debe ser flaca
con esto no quiero decir que no hay que
hacer chistes sobre las mujeres deben
ser flacas pero sí que preguntarnos de
qué nos reímos no sirve para tomar
conciencia porque nosotros podemos hacer
humor reforzando estereotipos o
combatiéndolos pero tenemos que tomar
conciencia sino la cosa no cambia
de todas formas yo pienso que lo peor
que podemos hacer en este caso es jugar
a la comediante que hace el chiste si el
feminismo
además de una teoría es una práctica y
se construye a base de permitirnos
equivocarnos para replantearnos y
cambiar
por eso digo el que esté libre de
mandatos que tire la primera piedra se
parte de un show cuyo nombre es la
traducción literal del stand up y lo
femenino
al principio la verdad no no
reflexionamos mucho sobre esto sabe el
nombre de wasabi quedado fuera el grupo
a está bueno nombre el show no nos dimos
cuenta pero de repente terminamos con
este logo la chica del baño fucsia fondo
negro con el micrófono y de repente un
día nos dimos cuenta que estábamos
actuando en calzas súper apretadas y
brillosas y tacos y frenamos hija
esto representa como que tuvimos hace
una cuneta que decir esto no puede ser
esto es terrible que hicimos entonces no
tuvimos mejor idea que agregarle un
bigote al logo horror de horrores pero
bueno lo importante es que hoy por hoy
nuestro vestuario muestra gráfica se
adapta un poco más a lo que somos
nosotras pero sin duda el primer punto
de partida fue prender el signo de
interrogación y modificar cada vez que
la alarma no son nada con la respuesta
hasta ahora les hable de humor porque es
a lo que me dedico
pero es importante que nos demos cuenta
que los estereotipos los mandatos los
prejuicios los reproducimos una y otra
vez en todos los discursos que circulan
en la sociedad en todos y cada uno de
ellos
tenemos que tomar conciencia de esto si
realmente queremos cambiarlo show hoy
escuché una publicidad en la radio era
una prepaga y decía the seas y esperarla
por 40 minutos afuera del probador de
recuerda por qué elegiste lo bueno se
hace esperar
mi idea es que en este momento
transformemos la pregunta de qué nos
reímos en qué ideas hay detrás de esto
es la pregunta clave
ideas hay detrás de esta publicidad que
las mujeres aman inter de shopping que
tardan 40 minutos en el shopping que
arrastran al hombre esta situación que
los hombres tienen que aguantar esta
situación porque las mujeres se tienen
que hacer desear que las mujeres se
tienen que ser histéricas con los
hombres podemos seguir así
reflexionando montón de tiempo antes de
que la prepaga sea el mensaje inicial
esto pasa con las mejores y las peores
intenciones hay publicidades que
intentan romper esto que de repente te
dicen un desodorante no te dice te dice
resalta la belleza que hay en voz está
partiendo de la premisa de que la mujer
tiene belleza en algún lado el cuerpo
tiene que tener belleza sólo tiene que
detectar en qué lugar y resaltar la esto
pasado también con los desodorantes de
hombres a los hombres no se les exige
que escondan el rollo no se les exige
que sean un exponente de belleza pero de
repente una publicidad desodorante de
hombre que tiene el eslogan hasta los
angeles ca eran ideas hay detrás de eso
que si sos hombre tú norte tiene que ser
concretar la mayor cantidad de
encuentros sexuales posibles porque ese
es el ideal masculino
si yo lo que quiero ahora es proponerles
un juego cuando se vayan de acá a lo
primero que encuentren en los medios ya
sea no se ve en la tele y en la radio en
la calle un afiche una publicidad hagan
la pregunta qué ideas hay detrás de esto
porque esa pregunta nos habilita a hacer
otras preguntas simples pero que sirven
para que nos demos cuenta de que hay
detrás
yo lo voy a hacer primero chocó con un
ejemplo es un juego que a mí me interesa
hacer no sé si está tan copado visto
porque por preguntarse preguntarse a
veces es un poco molesto si no todos
haríamos a los niños en la del por qué y
eso claramente no pasa yo lo voy a hacer
con esta tapa de revista para
demostrarles cómo funciona el juego
vemos una mujer con una pollera
una aspiradora una camisa dice rubia y
con 25 kilos menos a seis meses de ser
mamá revela el secreto de su nueva
figura y el plan de casarse con pedro
por segunda vez antes de tener su tercer
hijo
por qué decidió dedicarse full time a la
familia y cómo alimentar la pasión en la
pareja ideas hay detrás de esto para ser
ama de casa hay que usar tacos y pollera
que tener una mano como escondiendo el
rosso hay que casarse más de una vez con
la misma persona
hay que elegir y ser ama de casa o ser
profesional porque es importante
inmediatamente después de ser madre
bajar de peso y teñirse de rubio el
juego funciona así
mi idea es que ustedes lo hagan cuando
salgan yo creo que preguntarnos es
fundamental porque la comediante que
hace un chiste reforzando que la mujer
debe ser flaca lo hace sin darse cuenta
que la premisa la mujer debe ser flaca
la bomba ardió desde todos los rincones
de su vida y tenemos que tomar
conciencia de esto hay comediantes que
te presentan como la vez a la dama la
diosa y lo hacen con la mejor intención
lo hacen como diciendo pidió un fuerte
aplauso usan esas categorías como si
está lejos por eso confío en voz y cómo
podrían categorías y cooperar con la
risa
tenemos que tomar conciencia de esto en
el humor y en todos los niveles de la
vida
por favor les pido que cuando salgan a
ganar este juego
tal vez me odien un poquitito por que
preguntarse es muy difícil además de
molesto es difícil porque cada vez que
hacemos una pregunta inevitablemente
estamos buscando una respuesta pero si
ustedes hacen este juego y se van y me
odian un poquito voy a estar contenta
porque iniciamos el camino a una
sociedad más igualitaria más justa y
sobre todo una sociedad que se ría de
mejores cosas
ser la diosa del estánda muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]